hi I'm no exact witch and I'm doing a
wired autocomplete interview
autocomplete autocomplete and this is
just the beginning how does novak
djokovic
pronounce his name novak djokovic try it
at home
how does novak djokovic train usually
with the record in my hands
how does novak djokovic slide on a hard
court I think sliding helps the change
of direction a quicker change of
direction I think it's because of skiing
I did a lot of skiing when I was younger
so I think that helps how many titles
does know like Djokovic have 73 74
something like that how did Novak and
Jelena meet Djokovic is her surname
right now because she became my wife she
used to play tennis we saw each other in
one of the local tournaments in in
Belgrade that's where we met she used to
be my girlfriend and before that she was
my friend and before that she was my
high school crush all right next one why
Novak Djokovic is called Norway there is
no meaning in and connection between
Nava canola doesn't mean anything it's
just I guess it's or actually there is
some form of a connection between NOLA
as a nickname to know like as a name but
there is no any other meaning for that
why is Novak Djokovic called Joker well
I did impersonations of other players on
the court and I think that made made me
famous I used to do it more and then I
figured that some of the players were
starting to take it too personal so I
just didn't do it anymore in public I do
it I do it at home why there's no a jock
which eat grass because I'm vegetarian
non kidding when I was younger I've
always dreamt of winning Wimbledon and I
wanted to do something different and I
didn't come up with a more original idea
so I thought I might as well just eat
some grass and a lot of people asked me
how does it taste and it's best freaking
grass in the world
why is no joke ooh it's a good role
model I don't know you guys tell me I'm
trying to be myself you know obviously
be authentic be original
you always have consciousness about you
know younger tennis players and athletes
looking up to me all right next one
what is Novak Djokovic what is no joke I
don't know it's just the name what does
Novak Djokovic eat for breakfast green
juices different cold-pressed juices
smoothies a lot of fruits
oatmeal's chia puddings stuff like this
love mango what does no joke which eat
during matches dates only dates they
have a lower glycemic index they don't
give you those spikes like instant
spikes and they bring you down like some
maybe other sugary foods or liquids and
they just maintain the right level of of
sugar in the blood and energy and it
just they just fit me very well I've
been in you know eating dates for last
10 years what language does Novak
Djokovic speak I speak Serbian Dobrev
Academy Hospital which is good evening
ladies and gentlemen I speak English at
least I try Italian buona sera signora
signore E and a little bit of Spanish
when us not just me amigos dobriy vecher
the dummy gospel which is very similar
yeah
whoa see I only turn quarter that's
Chinese but not for good evening it's
something else
what color are novak djokovic is ice can
you zoom in please
[Laughter]
greenish green brownish are they you
guys agree okay got it
awesome all right he's Novak Djokovic
the best ever
you tell me
is knowing you know a joke which an only
child know I have two younger brothers
in a family Marco in Georgia and they
both used to play tennis as well he's no
luck jock with your father I am a father
I have that blessing to be a father of
two wonderful children
angel Stefan and Tara they're five and
two years old I miss my children they
are not with me now they're back in
Europe but but I'll be with them very
soon and they they and my wife are the
most important people in my life that's
for sure
is normal Djokovic left-handed no I'm
right-handed it's a great asset to have
that's for sure in in our sport if you
play a two-handed backhand if you have a
strong and coordinated left arm it
definitely helps execute the shots
better actually Rafael Nadal plays with
left hand but he's I think and naturally
right-handed I did I did I do every
every few days once in a while just
under on the practice court just for fun
he's Novak Djokovic gluten-free yes I am
gluten-free since 2010 dairy-free and
refined sugar-free
I'm also plant-based it's the whole
evolution of my nutrition has happened
in the last ten years
I'm just healthier overall I have more
energy I sleep better as an athlete that
I recover better have better
concentration on the court I run faster
and also it's because of the the planet
obviously sustainability I think going
plant-based is the way awesome
next Novak Djokovic when is Novakovich
birthday's 22nd of May 1987 when did
Novak Djokovic start playing tennis I
was four years old it was in Serbia and
a mountain resort called Kopernik where
my parents used to run a family business
they were making three tennis courts in
front of the restaurant and I used to
help
the workers out and bring them beer and
different drinks and in return they
would allow me to play some tennis when
the courts were done so that's that's
the beginning of the love story who is
in Novak Djokovic players box logically
it's it's my my team my coaches my
agents and I have my wife of course
she's not always there but whenever she
can my parents my brother's my friends
some celebrity friends here in New York
as well because we are in New York if I
in my box see people that I care about
that care about me that support me and I
feel the positive vibe coming from them
then of course he does help me play
better does nomic Djokovic have a tattoo
I don't how fast is no exact which surf
I'm not a huge server so to say I don't
have one of the fastest serves on the
tour although I did serve over 130 miles
per hour several times my career which
which is quite a nice speed although
it's I'm comparing to some of the guys
like John Isner for example or Karlovic
these guys that serve you know over 140
regularly when will novak djokovic
retire I don't know that I'm not
thinking about the retirement at the
moment I do have a family of course and
the things are evolving in my life so to
say and I'm you know obviously 32 which
by many standards so to say or the
history of tennis players retiring is
I'm coming closer to the end but I still
love playing I still love competing and
as long as he's like that I'll keep
going all right and last one when did
Novak Djokovic become number one it was
in 2011 I won Wimbledon for the first
time two biggest dreams came true in one
day and had a memorable reception back
home in Serbia just one of these things
that
stick with you forever that you know
bring you joy and nicest memories and
inspire you to keep on playing him and
winning it was beautiful
who is Novak Djokovic coach my coach I
have two coaches Mary and Veda that has
been my coach for almost 15 years we've
been he's more than a coach to me he's a
family member a friend a mentor we we
met I think was back in 2006 I was
looking for a coach and my agent
actually at the time he brought him to
one of my training sessions in in Paris
and it's weird but I broke the record
painting session in front of him and and
I I didn't actually see him I broke I
was really I was not playing well I was
not feeling well I broke the record and
I turned around and I saw my parents
were standing in the corner with him I
was like oh my god he was supposed to be
my coach and now when he sees this no
way so I walked out and he welcomed me
with a we're the greatest of smiles and
he's like gave me a hug and he said I'm
here and let's let's get this you know
let's let's work together and I that's
when I fell in love with a guy I mean he
he's just an amazing amazing person who
does know a joke which play next I play
someone with a tennis racquet and I hope
I'll kick his ass sorry who are Novak
Djokovic parents my parents names are
surgeon it's my father and Dianna my
mother
they have gave a lot of energy and time
and support for my dream to come true to
become a tennis player and I am
eternally grateful for them I want to
thank everybody for going to Google
search
and typing my name and you know
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this and
I'll see you on the tennis courts very
soon ora ora ora ora ora our interview